we typically like me and my boyfriends
will separate and we're both lives of
the party are talking to everyone we
come back and we're like yeah we're a
team and then we go do our thing and
they're comfortable with me like hanging
out talking to friends I would view that
the same thing like I'm here with my
girls we're on only fans like we do only
bands I don't know but this is the same
problem I was talking about with my
brother dating an only fans girl because
it's me before us when it should be us
first like how are you gonna have a
family when it's but when it's my fam my
feelings and my emotions before us so
how do you know though as a woman that
that man is actually committed like
you're saying he's committed just like a
lot of you you say it so you don't
really know I don't even know it's not
even committed yet yeah you've only been
dating a month
you're never gonna know but you have to
go into things with good faith because
you have previous trauma you can't put
that on a guy who's done nothing he's
taking his previous trauma assuming that
we're gonna [ __ ] this millionaire
instead of trusting us he's saying like
I think that's pretty reasonable